good afternoon everyone my name is Sahil
malli
be talking about Lea's code tips and
tricks so my contact information is up
here if you need a copy of these slides
you know send me an email or tweet me or
anything but probably the best way to
get this content so this slides you know
is like if you go through the slides all
the demos I'm showing it each slide as a
youtube link at the bottom so I've
broken this slide this whole
presentation down and in are lots of
chunks so obviously this video itself
will also be online but you're
interested in a copy of this slide decks
and mini mail or just follow me on
Twitter or just you know shoot me an
email and all my sites so basically
you'll be able to find all this content
broken down into small digestible pieces
you know on my on my site as well okay
so a little bit about me I'm a
consultant trainer I'm a developer
hands-on and I have been working in the
Microsoft space for my whole adult life
but for the last five ish years I've
also been cross-platform so when Windows
8 came out and they introduced the stop
button I got frustrated with Windows and
I bought a Mac I tried liking Windows 8
I just couldn't handle it but then I had
to justify the cost of that expensive
laptop so then I started teaching myself
objective-c and
and Swift and all of that and that made
me miss visual studio a lot but but you
know that's how I basically became a
cross-platform dev then over the last
few years
javascript is becoming has been becoming
very very popular and javascript and
typescript and angular near these
technologies I feel very truly at a
turning point now where angular allows
you to say build applications that both
perform well and also you have the
ability to you know build taller
buildings because the code is much
better structured and the same thing
that we said about typescript
types have not that much about
performance but angular 2 is all about
performance I think it's amazing that a
dev time you can build an application
and then it's about you know 250 KB at
that time and the minify it and
and become the 11 KB application and it
runs you know 50 60 % faster without
making any chord changes this is huge
implications especially for some mobile
devices etc but the reason I bring all
that up is because you know that's what
I've been doing being a cross-platform
developer you know write code in
typescript and angular and run it
everywhere from desktops to it has an
electron app on web and certainly as
mobile applications embedded in the
xamarin shell but my main tool in doing
all of this has been vs code via scored
is you know Visual Studio code so the
Visual Studio the full version it's
becoming very heavy and I like Visual
Studio a lot so there's not a criticism
of Visual Studio that's becoming heavy
now when I see things like the rear 17
is going to run your unit tests as you
type code well it's a setting that can
be disabled luckily but you know that's
why we need laptops with 64 gigs of ram
that and the fact that I need to open
two tabs in Chrome so it visual should
your code on the other hand is very
lightweight it feels like notepad and
you know what it works and Linux and
Windows and Mac it's fabulous how good
it is and this has been my main tool or
IDE for the past you know since vs code
came out before we escort came out with
like looking at sublime atom brackets
was what I like when we ask or came out
is like ok everybody move aside you know
the boss is here ok so how many of us
here have used vyas code ok great
almost all of us how when was the last
time that visual studio code natural
visual studio froze are hung on you
never right and this is something I
bragged about two days ago and it froze
on me so like ok well bad timing
but practically speaking it almost never
freezes it's a it's actually a very good
IDE so in this talk I'll be talking
about various tips and tricks and in a
little introduction of what we s code is
so if you use the escort you're probably
familiar with this site right you can
download it from Mac
Windows and Linux it runs beautifully on
Boonta for instance and the first tip I
have for you is the insiders build not
just the insiders build but also the
previous bills because I have run into a
situation where they'd release something
and that breaks something that I
definitely need fixed and you know what
we are stored if you've been using it if
there's an update available as I say
there's an update available do you want
to download it right so I find myself so
if there's something that broke and I
can't wait for them to ship an update
now that the update comes out very soon
tomorrow but what am I supposed to do
today you know I have a deadline
frequently I'll just download the
insiders build it by then they've
already fixed an issue right especially
if it's a big issue so the first tip I
have is go to github.com slash Microsoft
slash leus code or go to cord or visual
studio comm slash insiders so the main
exe is called code and the insiders
build is cold - insiders right so the
core - insiders is a side by side
installation it can live with your main
vs and if in a situation where something
like truly breaks you can get the
insider build and you know get along for
another couple of days now if you're
really desperate you can also go back to
a previous version all the pieces that
all the source code is you know open
source just go to this github wrapper
and from there you can just go download
any the source code of any previous
build and just build it right so that's
another approach you can use okay and
actually with this actually I'm just
going to skip over slides and I'll just
dive into vs code so create a little
folder here there's not much in it this
is a shell I like to use on Windows it's
called commander so I'm going to let's
see let me just go ahead and clone a
repo I have so this is a github comm /
malloc sahil sah IL / and GX black so
this is a you know little open source
thing that I put out there it's a code
repo which allows me to build an
application for Linux Mac Windows
desktop apps and more
laughs for literally every platform is
in Cordova and a web app on all
platforms with single codebase so within
10 minutes we can have you know an
application running on all code bases we
time at the end of this talk I can
perhaps demo this but sticking with
topic here so I'm going to go in here
and let's open this wrapper in vs code
okay so this is the S code so the first
tip is the VA store has teams this is a
team I like to use but you know you can
use whatever team you wish so for
instance I can say ctrl P and just hit
you know greater than sign and theme and
I can choose to pick a different color
theme or a file icon theme so I can
choose to make it look completely
different and I can choose to have a
different set off in a file icons as
well so that's the first you know tip
that and there are other themes that you
can download from the marketplace and
you can have Visual Studio look and feel
exactly the way you like now what I'm
working on code especially when I'm
working on in a large file so let me see
if they I don't think this project has
okay there's somewhat of a large file so
you know when I'm working on code screen
real estate is it's very very important
especially when I'm on the road because
when I'm at home or in an office I can
connect external monitors but I'd like
to see a lot of lines of code it makes
me more productive so one thing you can
do is that you can add f11 and it goes
full screen right just like the normal
visual studio does and to get out of
this mode you hit f11 again and actually
one thing you can do is that you can
what they call is toggle Zen mode and
you don't want to see anything this is
the file you're focusing on this is all
you care about
you can enable Zen mode right and this
is the only file that will occupy your
entire screen and to get out of that
mode you escape twice and you'll be out
of Zen mode oh and if you miss visual
studio too much and you would prefer
that this sidebar be on the right-hand
side you can just toggle the sidebar to
the right I've gotten used to the left
side pull back and all of these UI
elements the status bar this I think
it's called to dock or something like
the activity bar
and the panel and all of these things
can be hidden or shown and you know you
can completely customize this look and
feel to your liking all of this is
stored in your profile as a file and you
can stick that file in onedrive or
Dropbox and will even sync it across
multiple machines now there are
extensions available that all those
extensions will make this think a little
bit more smooth so there's a chance of
Visual Studio code might introduce that
setting in it but as of now you can just
put that file in Dropbox and or whatever
you prefer and you'll just think the
settings across all of your machines ok
now as I'm working on a big tight strip
project for instance so let's go into
the to the app folder and one of the
things I really like about typescript is
that it'll tell me if there are problems
before I build right so I can save you
so what other things say you see this
tilde over here as I cannot find angular
core because I haven't done an NPM
install yet so let me do that in the
background but one of the things I like
to do is I say view and I say view
problems they go to view problems and it
tells me if there are any problems in my
entire name so it's a typo or anything
like that typescript helps catch those
errors for me and I can just go ahead
and you know click on any one of these
errors and it takes me right exactly
where that error is just like I expect
out of the C sharp project and Visual
Studio so I have the same power here now
let's go back into some it's a package
store Jason a lot of us might be
familiar with a package or jason is but
sometimes my point here is that you
don't into these large files that you
want to add it and there is a long
repetitive code change that you need to
make so for instance I want to update
the angular version here so I don't know
what the latest version is I'm just
going to backspace this out and I'm
going to hit control space and if I'm
online thankfully I am there stuck if I
wasn't and if I'm online it'll tell me
what are the latest versions available
so that's good so two point four point
three but I need to go and replace all
these 2.0 2.0 point three how do I do
that obviously I can go type it
everywhere but one interesting thing you
can do is that when you have a cursor
here you can hold the Alt key down
and you can you know click at multiple
places and that gives you multiple
cursors
now whatever edit I do is going to go at
all of those multiple locations now
obviously I'm using a trackpad and you
know I suck at it so I click that a
bunch of wrong places really what I want
to do is that I want to replace all
those 2.00 so it's 2.4 whatever that
version was I forgot but what I can do
is that I get a ctrl F and I can search
for 2.0 and instead of hitting Enter I
will hit alt enter and I get multiple
cursors as you can see and now any
change I make goes everywhere right so
that's another really cool trick that I
find myself using a lot multiple cursors
okay now Visual Studio code I'm not
going to save this file so don't you
okay the visual studio code is loaded
with shortcuts and it takes time to
learn those shortcuts but there are two
shortcuts that you need to remember
everything else Visual Studio will teach
them to you one was control space that
gives you intelligence so anywhere you
want Intelli censored control space
it'll give you intelligence but a really
cool shortcut is when you need help what
do you say f1 right so a really cool
shortcut is f1 so anywhere in Visual
Studio code you hit f1 and that opens
the command palette and command palette
there are a lot of interesting things
you can do in command palette so when I
hit backspace I can jump from any file
to any file very quickly
for instance I have a big project and
especially if you were working with
angular for instance I'm sure other
platforms have the same challenge that
your code is getting fragmented into
numerous files I have a apt art
component es apt art component are HTML
and there are you know best practices
and naming standards but I just want to
jump to that one file very very quickly
this is backspace type the name of the
file whichever one you're trying to jump
to it takes you right there wherever it
might be in your project and our if you
noticed but files that were node modules
will actually groups
lately right so files that you are
interested in your source code and node
modules it allows you to jump to the
node module files but the files that are
in your source code are grouped
separately so you can jump to them very
easily
but there are a whole bunch of other
things you can do here as well for
instance I can hit this greater than
sign and this greater than sign shows me
a bunch of commands that I can execute
here and on the right side of the
command it shows me what keyboard
shortcuts I can like what keyword chart
that I can use to execute that command
without going through this rigmarole
right and another thing I can do is
let's actually jump to a slightly more
interesting file like a slightly bigger
file is what I was looking for well okay
let's let's take this big JSON file well
no that's minified okay I have a JSON
file on my disk here so something that's
like not minified and this data
txt is a JSON file that is not many
files I'm just going to drag drop this
here okay so it is a dot txt file but
the dark text file is actually a JSON
file so if there was an extension to it
visual studio code will automatically
understand that this is the extension
you're trying to use but here I don't
have that choice but I can tell Visual
Studio code that this is not plain text
this is actually a JSON file so let me
type JSON here and now Visual Studio
code will start recognizing this as a
JSON file and inside of the JSON file
also you have good intelligence if you
have tied it to a schema it'll use the
schema and you'll even even give me like
a basic editor with the schema but if
you're not using a schema it will just
parse this jason and it will try and
give you the best possible intelligence
it can give you for instance under tags
here when I hit control space it looks
at the structure of this JSON file and
it will basically tell you here these
are the other tags you're using and that
just makes editing this file a whole lot
easier but if that's not the point that
I was driving towards the thing that I
was driving towards was this f1 key and
here I can back
start out and hit act right and this ad
parses the symbols in this file and lets
me browse across these various portions
you see where I'm the highlighted
portion down there now where I find is
really really helpful is that if I run
into a big type script file or a c-sharp
file and and I want to jump from method
to method to method right so quickly it
will show me all the method names here
and I can quickly jump from method name
to method name and so on so forth
and act works within this file but if I
wanted to do this across my entire
project I hit hash and then I can you
know search for something and now it's
going to make me look like a fool
because I have a space there okay let's
close this let's try it again
so no symbols matching that's where
maybe I really don't have any symbols
there okay let's try it one more time
and I'll move up for this yeah so
basically like it can it you know with
hash I have the ability to go across my
entire project and I can search for a
matching symbol like that right so that
is very very cool another thing is that
at any point I can it question mark as
it says up there
and I can get help on the actions I can
take so for instance EDD show all open
editors or ext manage extensions right
so there's a lot of things that I can do
right through it or jump to a line or
you know so and so forth so the word
commands it supports you know it also
sort of splaine's itself to you as it
goes okay so that is the main keyboard
shortcut you need to know F one and from
there
you can discover other shortcuts now the
next tip is especially true when you're
working with a typescript project so for
those of us that have been working with
angular they've come out with something
called as angular CLI which basically
sets up an angular project for you so
one of the challenges these days with
you know building projects with any of
these latest frameworks react angular
whichever is framework part should I use
webpack
should I use browserify should I use
systems yes what sort of es6 polyfills
should I use rxjs how much should I
import when oh and then I need to build
support for a or T and that is a certain
different way of doing things and so on
so forth
now angular CLI basically shortens that
life span for you but angular CLI is
also you know like big and complex and
it's being built so one of the
complaints people have about angular CLI
is that you know when we're when I'm
working on a project I want live reload
right so if I save a type script file it
needs to get converted into JavaScript
and then my browser needs to refresh and
this should happen very quickly because
I'm in the middle of debugging I want to
see what's going on it might make a
little CSS changing I want to see
exactly what's going on I want that
feedback loop to be quick now in larger
projects with angular CLI because it
does bundling and minification and all
of that with every f5 you know it may
take two seconds five seconds even up to
12 seconds right
obviously that is annoying to the
developer and the other challenge is
that introduced so you know we're
fighting two different challenges here I
don't want to see what types of file
until I'm ready to reload but then it
becomes annoying because I have to
continuously remember to save the file
especially when I'm going from file to
file to file I may have say this file a
message that's file but I forgot to save
that one file and now I'm puzzled why my
code isn't working right so what are the
really useful settings that I have found
is files autosave and actually before I
talk about files out to save let me talk
about settings in general so you can it
control P and just type settings so it
takes you to a file called settings or
Jason in a folder called RDS code but
actually we're interested looking at you
know settings in general so I'm going to
greater than sign in its settings and
there are two kinds of settings
available user settings and workspace
settings workspace settings are specific
to your this project and those settings
are in a file here vs code and setting
star Jason so by anything that I've put
in this settings or Jason is something
that I intend to check in
and my whole team is going to share
these settings but then maybe there are
some settings that I like and I don't
want to share with the rest of the team
but I would really like to have them and
I want them for my workspace and those
are workspace settings that go into your
profile and basically you go here you go
to somewhere say settings and with the
open user settings right and when I say
open user settings here I have the
ability to write settings that are
unique for me and here I can say file so
there are a lot of you know this again
there's a lot of intelligence here with
some help to it second save files dot
autosave and I have the ability to say
off after delay on focus change and on
window changes new so fortunately what I
like to do is that I like to set after
delay and then you can specify a file
save delay autosave delay in
milliseconds so that way it doesn't you
know keep on churning all the time but
when I make changes I'm going to go from
file to file the file it's a little bit
more logical for me so this is my
personal favorite setting when I'm
working with typescript code but your
personal favorite settings may be
different also there are a couple of
other settings here that I find very
useful for instance HTML suggests
angular 1 angular 1 intelligence is
baked into vs code and so is ionic but
what if I'm not working on an angular 1
project or ionic then then that
intelligence becomes annoying right I'm
trying to write ng something that says
ng - app no I'm not trying to write ng -
app and then I have a backspace in a fix
but you can disable that intelligence at
the global level right another really
cool tip that I'd like to share with you
is this line here so frequently what
happens is that when I'm working in a
type script project the types of
extension is dot TS and then a dot JS
file you gets created at the same path I
mean you can control the path but the
best practices' is that you let
something like web pack handle the
minification and all that
for you so typically speaking we would
have our dart Jas act this path you
don't want to see the dot J s and dot j
s start map in your project structure
because the doc TS is what you are
focused on so you can hide those dot J's
files but on the other hand there is a
file here called JSP m dot config dot
J's I am interested in seeing that file
so what I'd like to say is that I'm
interested in hiding the dart J's files
that have an equivalent dot TS file next
to them right so basically I say hide
the dot j SS when a similar name dot TS
is present right so that's another very
very useful tip especially if you're
working on type Script projects now
another thing as I said that I like to
use this terminal here the reason I like
to use commander that's the name of this
terminal is because you know in this
sort of development environment you
frequently run into you know if I'm
downloading a project since a kid I run
into a lot of code that was written on a
Mac or Linux machine and they are using
commands like CP copy MV freedom or move
right
those commands don't work in DOS prompt
or even PowerShell or perhaps you want
to use PowerShell you know maybe when
you say that I want to use terminal and
I want to use PowerShell so one thing I
would like to do over it's a right-click
open and command prompt and you notice
here that it opens commander it didn't
open command prompt this is also
configurable in vs code how do you do
that again that was in settings so if
you go to my user settings this terminal
that external dart windows exact and
that will basically open whichever Exe
you point into the default value is
percent comes back percent which is
cmd.exe
right now via score also has a terminal
built into it and you can go view and
there is well the the terminal is it I
forgot I remember the shortcut it's like
control backtick but here you go
integrated terminal and you have the
ability to
use a different integrated terminal as
well so on a Mac for institution prefer
to use item you can configure that via
settings as well and another tip that is
connected to that is that if it control
shift back kick it will open two
terminal windows literally yes code okay
that's actually one of the most annoying
things about the toriel built in here is
that you can only one window know you
can actually open more than one right
speaking of commander not connected to
vs code why do I prefer to use this is
because I can search in the log you know
I can it control f and I can search for
say lazy and it defines it for me and
actually there are a bunch of things I
like about this so far I can the
derivative Microsoft calm and I get on
well not enter and I kick the control
key down and I can hover over this just
click on a link you'll take me to
Microsoft or come for instance there are
a lot of things I like about this
reciter so what are the things I really
like you notice this thing on the right
basically it shows me what branch I'm in
it's a git repo so it tells me a branch
I'm in and if I make a chord change
there that green will turn into yellow
right so it tells me like okay you're in
this branch but you made some chord
changes there so that's very very cool
okay so I talked about hiding files and
folders now let's talk about Emmett okay
let's create a new file and I'm going to
say that this is an HTML file and Emmett
you might know about Emmett is you know
it's it's basically productivity if
you're writing HTML so for instance what
I can do is that I can type HTML tab tab
and it basically completes it out to
slash HTML and if I want to create an
Alaia element on some extensions
installed here so it may interfere with
the extensions but let's try so see
there is html5 snippets that's an
extension I have installed but let's see
if Emmet works with the extensions
actually doesn't so I'll have uninstall
the extension before I can demo this but
what would have happened there is that
this would have created five allies for
me very quickly so you might have seen
this in demos
cetera that you go to in this like cheat
sheet for Emmett's this darkstar m8 r io
and slash cheat sheet here and then a
whole bunch of these you know shortcut
keys that they have that really shorten
the time you know as you're writing HTML
it really helps out but personally I
mean Emmett school I think is great for
demos personally what I like to do is
that I've just installed an extension
and you know I just have HTML snippets
created for me so for instance like now
it won't show up great let's try it one
more time
HTML tab tab for instance and and Ally
yeah yeah so basically like I have this
I some extensions and they're
conflicting with Emmet but if you don't
have those extensions you know you can
use them okay so there are I was talking
earlier about keyboard shortcuts there
are a ton of keyboard shortcuts built
into vs code so you just search for
keyboard shortcuts and you can say
keyboard shortcuts reference control K
ctrl R at any point and it enter and it
takes you to a via you know page hosted
on the internet which shows you all of
these shortcuts that you can use now I'm
not you know I haven't brought all of
these into my personal coding experience
I think the more you learn the better
you get especially these basic editing
ones I'm not familiar with all of them
but you know if you don't clienti you
can check that out but what's really
cool is that you can customize keyboard
extensions and you can make your own
keyboard extensions so for instance you
can say keyboard extension shortcuts
here and here you have the ability to
you know basically customize whatever
keyboard accessories are the extensions
that are available in vs code and then
key bindings are Jason and by the way
you could also put a key binding star
Jason and the dark Gnaeus code folder so
for instance one of the things I find I
miss in we escort it just in a hitting
f5 to start my project you can sort you
can create a keyboard extension but
the f5 is better handled with by another
file called tasks dar jason so their
task there's a concept for tasks envious
and vs cold I'll talk about that in a
second
but you can create your own extensions
and you see that if you go down here
some of these extensions are actually
two extensions in one for instance let
me see if I can find one I just go past
one okay I guess I can't find them now
but there are a few like control gate
control control K control R for
instances one well basically that's like
you know you hit control K and then you
have to hit control R so you can pair
you know two keywords and then what
commands can you put on those extensions
what is or this keyboard short Abell is
this list over here so any of these
actions you can define a shortcut for
right so that's keyboard shortcuts now
one of the languages that is becoming
very popular lately error in language is
the right word board the way to write
documents is markdown write markdown is
becoming very popular especially amongst
developers where you want something they
can just write opinion as a notepad and
it looks readable in notepad but it can
also be formatted by you know perhaps a
blog engine it can be easily converted
to HTML so this markdown is like you
know it's a HTML mark-up so it's very
complicated there's a lot of power there
and then there is markdown which is okay
it gives you some basic stuff like
formats this is code or bold or italics
or something like that so a lot of these
projects will have readme dart MD that's
a markdown file so this is a markdown
file via score will colorize this for
you as you see well one other really
cool thing via score does is that it's
got this button over here that basically
shows you a preview of how this file
looks like right so as I edit this file
I'll get a live preview of it very nice
if I can see the preview side-by-side so
I can click this button here to move it
to the side and then when I close this
over here and now I have a live preview
of this
on the right-hand side right so as you
know the readme dot MD if you put this
in like a gift wrapper oh that becomes
soon as a readme of that that particular
wrapper on the home page so yeah so
that's markdown so it comes with a built
in mark on preview editor whatever you
want to call it okay let's quickly jump
to index dot HTML now I am a developer
which by definition almost means that my
designer skills suck so when I have to
do styles or CSS frequently I get
confused about what style applies where
because CSS syntax can get pretty
complicated so a background I spent a
lot of years in SharePoint please don't
hold that against me
so in SharePoint the CSS is what 12,000
lines long is just crazy right I didn't
build the product but the really nice
thing about vs code is that when I'm
doing some basics you know CSS developer
level CSS let's call it that and what I
can do over here is that lets say that I
wanna be fancy and I say some fancy
style and I'm going to say background
colors it's nice it shows me how that's
cool and taking it control space and
again nice intelligent but I want to be
fancy and I want to use hex codes and
I'm going to say I don't know like 50
672 32 cool
so I picked a nice color apparently but
another thing is that I forget this hash
thing that you see on the left over here
right that hash syntax is that for an
element or is that for a cloth now I
know that many in the audience here
they're way smarter than me and you'll
just tell me come on that's what an
element okay
but I'm not that smart so what I do is I
just go over here and I hover over this
and it tells me exactly where that style
will apply so isn't that cool how many
of us knew this tip this small thing but
this is really cool now of course there
see it gets like really really
complicated where it cannot be sure
in a simple tool tip because CSS can get
fairly complicated you can say the third
child of this Li has this color and it's
calculated using javascript you know I
mean you can go really crazy with this
so obviously it won't help you to that
limit but simple stuff like you know the
end child or you know a dot or a hash or
an element name it'll help you with that
basic CSS stuff right so that's very
very cool okay let's quickly jump over
to packaged art Jason somebody is
actually asking this question over
breakfast glad I was able to answer it
because it is package a Jason this is
how we're describing our projects these
days even in dark net code this is what
we do so in package dot Jason you know
you saw the little intelligence will see
what's really cool is that I can in that
double quote there and I can hit control
space the global shortcut for you know
anywhere you want to see intelligence
and this right there basically queries
all the node packages available for you
that are not even install in my project
and I can pick any one of them gives me
a little help for them depending upon if
they put any help there and I can it
enter and then here like what version do
I pick again I can add control space and
it tells me what I messed up so I can
hit control space there and it tells me
hey what version is available for this
package right so it really really helps
me manage my package star Jason but
that's just dependencies what about the
other things what about the schema for
for for packages audition and well it is
good intelligent for that as well for
instance I can control space and I can
you know pick any one of these things
there and you know just write this up
and it gives me a little helpful you
know so for instance licenses okay so
what is the help for this and you clicks
click this exclamation mark is a nice
help go back and so on so forth so it
helps you manage your package star Jason
as well not just package the audition
they have built schemas for most of the
common JSON files you run into and again
with help and so on so forth helps you
manage these files now
talked a little bit about get and this
project as you see that I am this is a
good project I downloaded from github
and that green thing is telling me that
basically that this is a project that
has not been modified and I'm on the
master branch that's commander but
actually there is some very good git
integration built into vs code as well
so for instance let me actually go ahead
and make some changes to let's make
changes to index dot HTML so I'm gonna
say this is this is a new line and I
changed this line and well actually I
should have changed line a little
further up because it's going to confuse
now I changed this line and this cord
over our JLS is deleted okay now right
there it is telling me there are these
little annotation on the left hand side
on the colors are coming out very well
on the projector but the top one is blue
that is a modified line there's a
triangle that is red that is a deleted
line and the green on the left are
edited lines right so right there it
tells me that you know these are the
changes that I've been done since the
last commit but if I want to see that
visually I can click on this here switch
to the changes view I can click on this
and it shows me a more you know visual
view of what are the changes that have
been done and if I want to view this and
say how git shows I can even do a show
you know switch to inline view and I can
see it like that as well right so it is
a fantastic dipping tool this is
actually one of the things that people
install windows and I'm like why are you
installing windows when you have vs cold
for instance here if I go into let's go
to the WB folder CD app LS and so let's
say that app dot component RTF and there
is an app dot component RTF and I want
to compare those two files there's two
arbitrary files so I can set code and if
I forget the command I
can say - - help and it tells me all the
commands that are available and one of
the commands that is available is this
the bunch of other interesting commands
as well but the command that I find my
full using a lot is obviously this and
disabled extensions because they
download a bad extension that is causing
things to go crazy like we saw the MS
thing broke then you can just load it
with disabled extensions anyway second
set code - - diff and say after
component rjs app start component RTS
hit enter and it opens those two files
in at this view and actually you don't
even need to go that far you can do this
right
within vs code so you just go here you
say okay I want to compare let's say
after routing the TS I'm going to say
right-click select for compare and
compare with app guard module dot es and
compare with this file and it shows me
comparison right so via code is a very
very nice dipping tool as a different
comparison it's just it's very good for
that nicely you know colors of things
and so on so forth speaking of git
integration as I make changes to the
file so I'm going to make a random
change here so let's see if commander if
you see the color here change the
commander picks it up that's cool but
you see that this thing lit up over here
is telling me that there is a change to
a file and I can just go over here and I
can you know see what what changes what
file was changed what change was done I
can choose to state it I can choose to
clean it and I can choose to commit it
as well but I'm terrible at git I want
to learn good commands as I go so you
can do this you can save view output and
make sure the enable output for git and
it will show you what gate commands vs
code has been executed in the backend
under in the background right so this
way you see exactly what's going on and
then when your coworker comes let me do
it from command line and just totally
blow him off right this is really really
cool okay I'm going to clean this change
and come back here
okay so I talked about different files
are talking about git integration and
when I'm working on a big project when
I'm working on a big project I you know
I'm frequently working on number of
files and one thing I really really like
about vs code is that when I click on
this one file it opens it here but you
notice that this title bar is in italics
that's basically telling me that it's
not sticky so for me too if I first open
another file it would reuse that same
window so it's not opening too many
windows it's are creating clutter but if
I want that one file to stick there I
double click on that or I edit the file
same thing and it'll make it sticky now
when I open another window or another
file it'll open it in a new window but
what if I wanted to open in a second
pane
you know like this painter you have the
ability to create multiple panes I think
you go with three or four depending on
the screen size so if I wanted to open
this after routing or TS side by side
without going through all this complex
you know force I open this and I go over
here and open it I used to do that for
months but I discovered a really nice
shortcut you will hold the ctrl key down
and then you click on a button and it
opens it on the side like it's a very
small tip but it's a huge time-saver
when you're trying to arrange these
files anyway when you're thinking code
you want the computer in your mind to be
one you don't want the tools to get in
the way right so these things really
matter okay
speaking of which next let's talk about
extensions extensions are really really
cool extensions are what make vs chords
so awesome so I'm going to control P by
the way you can just go to this button
here and that'll show you all the
extensions these are my favorite
extensions angular 2 type strip snippets
if you're an angular 2 developer writing
you'll find them really useful I do
think that there will be replacements
for this coming you know officially from
the team as well but as of now this is a
huge time-saver Auto rename tag is
useful but I'm working on HTML and if I
have a you know h1 tag and I want to
quickly change it to an h2 if I change
an h2 one it will just automatically
match it on the other xlm is a demo that
will be here so let's create a h1 tag so
for instance here if the h1 tag / h1 so
it matches it and I'm going to put some
text in the middle and imagine that this
was a very complex file and I want to
change this tag
you know like it'll match it on both
sides and we'll change it so there's a
small time saver right so that is that
is the HTML auto rhenium tag CSS class
completion is really nice especially if
I'm working the frameworks like
bootstrap etc or MDL for material design
of material 2 is coming out which is
really nice but it's it's just entered
beta but before that you know we we use
these frameworks that are all these
classes in a bootstrap as all these CSS
classes that I need to know and what
this does what this extension does is
that it looks at your entire project
and sees all the CSS styles that are
available to you in that page and will
show them to you in intelligence right
so that's very very cool and the HTML
snippets is just as the name suggests
it's HTML snippet and if I want to
install more extensions I can say you
know click this button here and what are
the really cool ones I like is the show
recommended extensions so the show
recommended extensions they can just
like add recommended up there and what
that does is that it looks at what file
extensions do you open the most and
based on that it'll tell you hey these
extensions might be of interest to you
right it's actually another extension
that I really like is the visual studio
tools for Apache Cordova so I just go up
here I can just search for talk for
while the search for Cordova they
already have it installed no I don't so
I can just click this I can install it
give it a second
installing and then relearn the window
and it'll basically enable that right so
now that extension is available for me
to use and if I was in a Cordova project
then basically I can just go to this bug
looking thing here and I can basically
tell it that already I've already done
that for this project so you don't see
it here but basically here when you
click on this gear you can configure
this project to be like you can tell
this for what kind of project this is
this is this a Cordova project it is an
old project as a darknet project so I've
already told it that this is a that this
is a Cordova project and then I can just
you know choose to run Android on
emulator and hit this play button here
and it will build this part because this
is also an android project apparently
there's some errors here because I did
not add the platform Android user
Cordova Cordova platform add Android
Justin I will do that give it a second
okay Android project created let's give
it a second yeah this project is really
cool the one that I'm using is the test
dummy that basically lets you you know
write your code in this app folder here
and let's close this so basically let
you in a write your code in this app
folder here and whatever code you write
here since a simple angular apps is just
one route and to do button and all that
and it'll basically run that same code
as both Cordova and electron and as a
web page and better command for this in
the package store JSON file here up here
so if you run it as electron you do this
if you learn the code over just use
Cordova and so on so forth so is this
done yep now I'm going to come back here
and that file same that's cool let's
come back here run Android on emulator
hit play fingers crossed
launching for Android this may take a
while no kidding because it actually
launches a VM and it should if we're
lucky enough it should basically just
bring up Android and while it is
bringing that up I will actually go here
now we won't actually I don't think we
will hit a breakpoint in this because I
don't have any code here that'll
actually hit a breakpoint see have I
actually have no code in this but
basically like I could put a breakpoint
here at any one of these types trip
lines and this happens too soon so the
big point like the debugger get attached
after after the emulator pops open but
if I had some real code like if there's
a button and I click on a button and
some files are called and basically I
could put that code in here for instance
at a break point here and the break
point will get hit hit in vs code and
you'll see that once the s code attaches
it so I just had run on an emulator and
I can also do this on a device but I can
come here and I can say it's said run
Android on an emulator and let's give it
a second it should come up unable to
find ADB okay
confused so let's hope when we just go
to good old art and let's come back here
this is this guy running now as throwing
so matter but that's okay but what I can
do is a hit I can say a catch to running
Android and emulator and it display
button and something's messed up with my
environment right now but is if my
environment was healthy
both on Mac and Windows iOS and Android
I can directly attached to this running
emulator right here and debug the code
right through the S code right so that's
another possibility the thing is like
you know as a cross-platform dev on a
daily basis I'm going between xamarin
studio Cordova Visual Studio and it
things just break you know the
environment breaks all the time and I
have to fix it but that's okay we're not
going to do that because this talk is
about vs code so we'll we'll stick with
that and that brings me to the final
most important slide which is thank you
and if you need this slide deck please
email me here but you can find all the
tips on my Twitter account as well or
just follow my blog and you'll find all
of these tips being written out as
videos on my site as well let's give a
second load my online I'm connected
apparently but anyway so once my site
loads you'll see that there are you know
blog posts are for blog post and I
literally like each one of these tips
that I shared today is shared as like a
one-minute video snippet it won't take a
lot of time and I'm you know tweeting
these as I discover more things I just
quickly recorded in a 1-1 and a half
minute video put it online it's not
going to take a lot of time out of your
day
yeah I'm offline so whatever but yeah so
that thank you very much I'd love to
take any questions at this point
and thank you for attending
[Applause]
it's definitely offline that sucks
but whatever yeah yes that's in launched
our nation and that demo is going to
fail because my cordova setup is broken
but basically the first command in here
gets called they need f5 so with vs cord
you can do this control p cost and first
thing is a configure task runner so like
if using NPM Tao sort of using gulp
grunt whatever so you tell it what kind
of task manager you are using and the
first task is that fight so whatever you
connect with f5 it'll run so yeah so if
you're like Cordova project f5 it'll
just start Cordova Android and attach
whatever whatever you configure it to do
basically I think the that prob most
likely the reason that Cordova thing is
failing is because of the network
because it connects over the network to
to enable debugging but let's not worry
about that right now
cool
I haven't seen any I haven't seen any
extensions for unit testing but
personally my experience in unit testing
and this is basically mostly doing
angular and I just know the Karma and
Jasmine mocha those are the things I use
so you just like the dark specter key is
right where your component or your
service is and the you know angular CLI
has got ng e2e or basically the two
command III and run test and you can
just run the test right there and then
that also integrates very well with your
you know like when you check it in and
with Jenkins it will just run it for you
so you can very easily just point and
click configure and on online tasks run
or to test your class as well any
extensions for that I haven't seen
anybody ever needed any so I really
wasn't looking for any the JavaScript
project that's really all you need
anywhere yeah
it is it is portable already because
it's cold dot exe you just pick it up
from your machine its electron app the
vs code is written in typescript that's
the most amazing thing but there is an
installer and there is a zip file on the
download page and even if it's an
installer just go and drop the code that
exe and just you can just take that with
you on a Mac is that it's a dart app
file and that will also run off of a USB
stick somebody else had a question
well they do not get extensions that'll
show you like a get logs and they'll
show you what branch you're on and I'll
show you like there's an extension
they'll get blame but when it comes to
like merging to be honest I haven't
found a single tool that does that very
well when it comes to like merging its
it almost always boils down to
command-line anyway one of the tools I
like is get cracking which shows me a
very nice you know view of how the
branches have been splitting and merging
so that's one of the most nicest desktop
tools I know if it's not vs cord but
actually that tool is also an electron
app so that is also a JavaScript thing
but not in vs code there's some
extensions for you know git log that's a
nice one but for merging and all not
really
okay when it comes to debugging
javascript court personally my favorite
tool is still the chrome debugging tools
there is a most popular extension here
right now is the chrome debugger
extension honestly why I don't
understand why you need it it's the most
popular extension so maybe I'm missing
something
but the chrome debugging tools are so
damn good and actually I have a video on
Chrome debugging tools that I'll tweet
later frankly why would you need
anything else is the chrome debugging
tools are fabulous so I just use those
vs chord has the ability to connect to a
running Chrome extension in chrome
browser and then you can debug through
visual studio code I really don't find
that very useful to be honest it's good
but the chrome debugging tools are
better so I just use those that's
personally what I do if chrome debugging
- there's so many tips and tricks there
holy crap like that's another talk that
it's like when I show those tips and
tricks everybody's like wow there's some
good stuff there I wish I had time to go
into those sorry I wish I'll talk on
that here but chrome debugging is
fantastic but every video on that online
and I'll tweet that maybe later tonight
okay so almost our time but I'll be in
the hall so there are any questions I'd
love to take them thank you